abstraction corrosive
c'est en ces termes que bertrand perron
définit son travail l'artiste expose
actuellement à l'hôtel de ville depuis
en cours une vingtaine d'oeuvres sont
visibles tout réalisé par la dégradation
ce sont des heures en fait
sur plaque d'acier et ses prédations en
fait je les fais rouillé voilà j'ai fait
rouillé avec de l'eau essentiellement je
peux rajouter le site des pigments des
dents mais c'est essentiellement oui
avec de l'océan procédé naturel fait
c'est un peu comme des vanités séoul et
quand on les regarde on peut se dire
sont comme nous l
évolua vieillissent elles vivent quelque
part c'est pas quelque chose de statique
un travail sur l'aspect éphémère de la
vie menée depuis 2008
cette réflexion lui est venue en
regardant la rouille qui se formait sur
une voiture j'avais un véhicule assez
vieux en très mauvais état qui rouille
est partout et je trouvais que cette
rouille sur la carrosserie était très
belle et
intéressante et qui avait quelque chose
à faire avec la cause c'est comme ça que
l'idée de travailler avec la cie ce qui
est aussi très intéressant enfin et de
verre trempé rossé qu'on voit que ces
oeuvres évolue vraiment entre les
moments où il décrit les moments où il
est exposé et peut-être même encore
d'ici quelques années on verra encore
des zones aux différents important c'est
toujours la même
tout comme ses oeuvres l'exposition de
bertrand perron est éphémère
elle est à découvrir jusqu'au 26
novembre